what do seven of the world's most elite
Grand Masters have on their schedules
this year they're all competing in the
strongest online chess tournament ever
on chess.com with unprecedented prizes
and an exciting knockout format the 2016
Grandmaster Blitz battle Championship
will change and Define the future of
what both fans and professionals come to
expect from online chess these top Grand
Masters will be paired off in
head-to-head Blitz and bullet matches to
decide the winner of the greatest and
strongest online event ever held let's
meet the players seated at number seven
the world's 14th strongest player by
classical chess and number two in India
behind only former world champion Vish
Anan pentala Hari Krishna is considered
by many to be India's best chance to
bring the world championship title back
to East Asia coming in seated at number
six is the world number three for
classical chess and the United States
highest rated player by classical
ranking Fabiano Carana Fabiano comes in
slightly underrated red as far as his
Blitz performances are concerned but
boast one of the best over theboard
records against world champion Magnus
Carlson look for Fabiana to Make Some
Noise with that low seating coming in at
number five is armenia's number one and
their best hope for a world championship
title leavon aronian currently ranked
number seven in the world leavon has a
2790 Blitz performance and is known as a
rapid specialist he may have slipped to
number 17 in the current live rankings
but don't let that fool you the rainning
World Blitz Champion Alexander gisha
comes in at number four and is
considered by many one of the favorites
to win this event having already taken
down Magnus Carlson last October in
Berlin seated at number three is Maxim
bash lrav currently ranked number six in
the world for classical chess and number
one in France mvl also boasts the
coolest nickname in professional chess
and will have as much as a home turf
advantage on chess.com as any player
perhaps besides Aaron Nakamura seated at
number two is of course the world number
five player by classical rankings hikaro
Nakamura considered by many to be the
best bullet and Blitz chess player of
all time hikaro will look to prove his
dominance as the king of the online
chess Arena on top of it all the
reigning world champion highest rated
chess player in history and considered
by many to be the best player of all
time Magnus Carlson perhaps the only
Arena he hasn't left his mark on as
clearly the best is the online chess
Arena will he do it in The Grandmaster
Blitz battle championship you'll have to
find out but what about the eighth spot
you've been paying attention our final
spot is reserved for any International
or Grand Master who can prove him or
herself worthy in our May 31st $5,000
cash prize fund qualification tournament
if the prizes Aren't Enough the winning
player gets to play Magnus Carlson in
the first round so there you have it
eight players will face off for a chance
at history not only the title of The
Grandmaster Blitz battle Champion but
the majority of the $35,000 cash prizes
all prizes made possible because of our
generous sponsors peop talk. Ru Indigo
Capital partners and Buon Venture
Capital so how can you the fan get
involved well you can enter in our
contest Bracketology opens up on March
14th with an article on chess.com
explaining all the details make your
picks submit it via our online entry
form and look for the top performing
brackets to take home chess.com premium
memberships as well as other cool prizes
every one of these matches will be
broadcast in multiple languages so fans
can get involved in the chat at
chess.com TV
twitch.tv/ as well as numerous other web
portals the first match takes place on
April 6th between World Bliss Champion
Alexander grishuk and armenia's number
one Theon aronian so before we let you
go we have to ask who do you think will
[Music]
win